Schönen guten Tag.
Schönen guten Tag. Ich bin Dr. Jisalton. Ich bin der Adizabender aus in dieser Praxis.
Ich möchte gerne heute mit Ihnen dieses Aufnahmegesprach führen.
Sind Sie damit verstanden?
Ja, natürlich. Hauptsache, jemand guckt nach mir.
Bevor Sie Ihre Beschwerden, Mia, erklären oder seelen,
möchte ich ganz schnell ein paar Fragen Ihnen stellen.
Ich meine, basic auf Ihr Altagrossgewicht.
Größer.
Und wenn Sie nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben,
geben Sie mir eine Bescheid und mache ich eine Kursepause.
Und wir klären das.
Ihre Fragen zu Wortmortem.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Anna Kehl.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Namen langsam bestehen?
Ja, der Vorname ist A double N A.
Ja.
Der Familienname ist K I H L.
Kehl. Okay.
Frau Kehl.
Frau Kehl. Genau.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Noch bin ich 67 Jahre alt.
67 Jahre alt.
Könnten Sie mir Ihr Gewusstrat verraten?
Ja, natürlich. Der 9., 10. 56.
9., der 9., 10. 56.
56.
Okay.
Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 79 kg schwer und ich bin so 1,68 groß.
War ich zumindest mal.
60 groß.
1,68 m.
Okay.
Frau Kehl, was kann ich wieder tun?
Was für eine Summe?
Ja, ich habe jetzt seit einigen Tagen solche heftigen Schmerzen
hier im Oberbauch.
Und da das immer schlimmer wird, habe ich gedacht,
jetzt muss ich doch mal kommen.
Sitten Sie, mein Hausarzt hat Urlaub.
Und bei den Vertretern, da habe ich niemanden ans Telefon bekommen.
Bin ich direkt hier in die Klinik gekommen.
Und das seit 2 Tagen wird das wirklich immer schlimmer.
Das Einzige,
das mir so ein bisschen Erleichterung gebracht hat,
ich habe mich 2-mal übergeben müssen.
Danach ging es mir beinahe besser als vorher.
Ja, aber das sind ganz schlimme Bauchschmerzen.
Okay.
Herr Kehl, Frau Kehl, ich schreibe Ihnen.
Ja, sind, haben die Schmerzen seit 2 Jahren,
begonnen richtig?
Nein, die haben schon länger.
Schon länger haben die begonnen, aber seit 2 Tagen sind die richtig schlimm.
Richtig schlimm, 2 Tage richtig schlimm.
Und sie haben 2-mal erbrochen.
Sie haben gesagt Oberbauch, wo genau diese Schmerzen,
rechte Seite oder linke Seite oder miedel?
In der Mitte würde ich sagen,
oder oberhalb vom Bauchnabel würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Und ganz besonders schlimm sind die Schmerzen direkt nach dem Essen.
Ich habe jetzt schon ganz vorsichtig gegessen die letzten Tage,
aber ein bisschen, was nimmt man ja dann doch zu sich?
Ich habe mein Zwieber gegessen und mal habe ich mir ein Brei gekocht
oder Pudding gegessen oder so.
Aber nach dem Essen tut es immer ganz doll weh.
Sie haben Pudding und könnten Sie das wieder rollen?
Ja, ich habe das.
Was haben Sie gegessen?
Ich habe Zwieber gegessen, also leichtes Essen
und habe mir mal ein Brei gekocht und mal ein Pudding gekocht.
Ja, weil ich dachte, das ist vielleicht gut für den Bauch.
Aber direkt nach dem Essen ist es ganz schmerzhaft.
Okay.
Und haben Sie auch Durchfall, oder?
Nee, Durchfall habe ich nicht, aber was mir aufgefallen ist,
dass der Stuhlgang, dass der so ganz dunkel aussieht, also fast schwarz.
Mhm.
Und schlapp fühle ich mich.
Also schlapp und mir ist ganz übel.
Also ich bin gar nicht mehr ich selbst.
Okay.
Seit wann fühlen Sie sich schlapp oder erschöpft?
Ja, also besonders jetzt seit diesen zwei Tagen.
Vorher habe ich immer gedacht, ach, das wird schon wieder die Schmerzen.
Das hat man ja mal.
Aber jetzt wird es überhaupt nicht besser und jetzt fühle ich mich richtig schlapp.
Okay, okay.
Aber besonders treten die Schmerzen nach dem Essen auf.
Oder schlimmer geworden.
Ja, besonders stark auch.
Ja, genau, die sind immer da.
Aber ganz schlimm ist es nach dem Essen, auch wenn ich noch so vorsichtig esse.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, zweimal Erbrochen.
Wie sieht das Erbrochen aus?
Magenrest, oder haben Sie im Blut bemerkt?
Also da waren Reste von dem Essen natürlich drin und ein bisschen Tee.
Da waren auch so ein bisschen rötliche Schlieren.
Das kann sein, dass da ein bisschen Blut mit dabei war.
Das ist schon möglich, ja.
Okay, okay.
Und so, könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ich meine, ist er dumm, sterb, serb?
Ja, so stechend ist es nicht und es brennt auch nicht.
Es ist eigentlich so ein dumfer, dumm verdrückender Schmerz.
Okay.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10 vorbei 1?
Sehr leckere Schmerzen sind sehr, sehr starker Schmerzen.
Wo würden Sie einordnen?
Das sind schon richtig heftige Schmerzen.
Ich würde vielleicht sagen so bei 7.
7?
Also schon deutlich über der Hälfte, ja.
Okay.
Und so strahlen die Schmerzen in einem anderen Körperteil aus, rücken oder unter Bauch.
Nein, die sind hier im oberen Bauchbereich.
Das strahlt nirgendwo hin. Nein.
Nein.
Mhm.
Nach dem Stuhlgang fühlen Sie sich besser oder gibt es bestimmte andere Faktoren für die Schmerzen auseressen?
Also besser fühle ich, habe ich mich gefühlt, nachdem ich mich übergeben habe.
Ja, also als er schlimmste so vorbei war, als es draußen war, den habe ich mich ein bisschen besser gefühlt, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder bekommen Sie Schwerluft?
Nein, das eigentlich nicht.
Was mir aufgefallen, ich habe so ein bisschen Husten in letzter Zeit.
Da kommt aber nichts eigentlich.
Das ist nur so gereizt.
Mhm.
Okay.
Haben Sie Herztoppen oder Herzrasen?
Nein.
Ich habe auch Schmerzen, aber im Herzen glaube ich nicht, dass ich irgendwas habe.
Okay.
Und, äh, herkiel, äh, Frau, haben Sie, äh, Frau, kiel, Entschuldigung, äh, haben Sie früher so was, äh, erleb oder ist das zum ersten Mal?
Das ist zum ersten Mal, das habe ich überhaupt noch nie gehabt durch die Schmerzen.
Und auch, dass mir so wahnsinnig schlecht ist, ja. Klar geht es einem mal schlecht und hat noch mal was Verkehrtes gegessen, aber, nee, dass man solche, dass ich solche Schmerzen hatte und, ja, auch, dass mir so wahnsinnig schlecht ist, nee, das habe ich noch nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch Feber, Stelfrost oder Nachtschweiß oder Auspül?
Also, heute Nacht und die Nacht davor ist mir aufgefallen, dass ich sehr geschwitzt habe, ja.
Ich habe dann überlegt, ob ich mich vielleicht zu, zu doll zugedeckt habe und, und ich fühle mich wohl auch ein bisschen heiß an, ja, doch.
Äh, haben Sie Ihre Körpertemperatur gemessen oder?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, nee.
Okay.
Und, äh, wie ist ja Appetit im Laufe der Zeit für Sex?
Der, also der Zeit ist der gegen Null. Also ich habe überhaupt gar keinen Appetit. Ich esse nur so ein bisschen aus Vernunft, aber das bekommt mir ja auch gar nicht gut, ja.
Wenn ich esse, wird mir ja gleich schlechter.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit der Sturrante?
Normalerweise nicht. Also manchmal muss ich Nacht einmal in der Nacht so auf die Toilette gehen zum Wasserlassen, aber normal habe ich eigentlich keine Schwierigkeiten.
Wie viel mal müssen Sie in der Nacht auf Toilette gehen?
Einmal, habe ich gesagt.
Okay.
Und, äh, haben Sie im Laufe der Zeit App oder Suche genommen?
Ja, tatsächlich habe ich in letzter Zeit zugenommen. Ich schieb das aber auf das Cortison, das ich nehmen muss.
Wissen Sie, ich habe so rheumatoide Atritis. Also, und da muss ich halt Cortison nehmen.
Und das lässt einen ja einfach immer wieder aufschwemmen.
Okay.
Und, äh, haben Sie Schlafstörung?
Normalerweise nicht. Die letzte Nacht habe ich natürlich nicht gut geschlafen und die Nacht davor nicht, weil ich eben wegen der Schmerzen auch immer wieder aufgewacht bin.
Okay.
Okay, äh, ja, äh, Frau Thiel, Sie haben gesagt, Sie leiden an Atritis.
Ja, ja, ja, die Gelenke sind alle irgendwie so gut.
Ich möchte über Ihre medizinische Folgeschichte schiebere. Leiden Sie an bestimmere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, also wie gesagt, diese Atritis, das habe ich, das schleppe ich jetzt schon seit zehn Jahren mit mir rum.
Und ungefähr genauso lange habe ich auch schon erhöhten Blutdruck.
Blutdruckdruck?
Mhm.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Ich sagte genau so lange, also zehn Jahre.
Zehn Jahre.
Und gibt es noch andere?
Ja, das langt mir völlig, ja.
Mhm.
Okay.
Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie nehmen Cortison ein.
Ja.
Wie viel Milligramm und kennen Sie, dass Medikamente heißt?
Ja, das heißt Pretnisolonen.
Mhm.
Und das sind 15 Milligramm, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Einmal oder zweimal?
Morgens einmal.
Na, na morgens.
Okay.
Und gegen Blutdruckdruck tun.
Ja, ich kriege noch ein Medikament, das heißt Kaptochril.
Kaptochril.
Das nehme ich morgens und abends.
Morgens, abends.
Mhm.
Wie stark wissen Sie?
Ich meine, da steht 25 drauf.
25.
Kaptochril, 25, doch ja.
Mhm.
Okay.
Und was noch, gibt es andere Medikamente oder das war das?
Ja, manchmal, wenn das also mit den Schmerzen in den Gelenken
so doll wie so schlimm ist, dann nehme ich bei Bedarf noch die Klophenack.
Die Klophenack, bei Bedarf.
Mhm.
Wie viel Milligramm, wie stark?
Ja, das sind 50 Milligramm, meine ich.
Okay.
Also 50 steht da drauf, ja.
Okay, okay.
Frau Kild, würden Sie schon einmal operiert oder würden Sie schon
in Krakenhaus eingeliefert liefert?
Eingeliefert, liefert.
Eingeliefert.
Also ich hatte mal eine Operation am rechten Knie, da war das rechte Kreuzband gerissen.
Und da, das ist operiert worden.
Also auch ist es aber schon ewig, da war ich ein junges Mädchen.
Mhm.
Ja, danke, Menschen.
Haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt oder was war passiert?
Ja, so ein Sportunfall damals, ja.
Mhm, okay.
Ja, ähm, Frau Kild, nehmen Sie auch Magenschutz-Tablet ein oder nicht?
Was soll das sein?
Magenschutz, ne, ne, ich nehme nichts anderes ein als die Tabletten.
Mhm, okay.
Okay.
Und so, Frau Kild, sind bei Ihnen eine bestimmte Medikamente,
oder Kontrastmittel allergie bekannt?
Wissen Sie?
Na, so viel ich weiß, habe ich keine Allergien, kann eigentlich alles vertragen.
Okay.
Mhm.
Und, äh, lehmensmittel Unverträglichkeit oder?
Nein, ich kann alles essen und trinken, was ich will eigentlich.
Okay.
Also nicht gerade heute, aber normalerweise?
Ja.
Lass uns über Ihre Gewohnheit sprechen.
Frau Kild, rauchen Sie?
Ja, also ich rauch schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren, ja.
Was meinen Sie, viel, viel Jahren?
40 Jahre.
Seit 20 Jahren rauch ich schon, ja.
20 Jahre.
Mhm.
Wie will Sigaret, äh, schaben Sie Protak geraucht?
Oh, ich rauch ein Päckchen am Tag, rauch ich schon, ja.
Ein Schachtel.
Okay.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Regelmäßig, ja so, 3-4 Mal in der Woche trinke ich wohl abends ein Glas Wein.
Entschuldigung, könnte Sie bitte das wiederholen?
3-4 Mal in der Woche trinke ich abends ein Glas Wein.
Ein Glas Wein.
Mhm.
Okay.
Und bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie eine Droge oder schon mal probiert?
Ob ich das schon mal probiert habe?
Nee, dafür habe ich viel zu viel Angst davor.
Also nee, mit Drogen kenne ich mich überhaupt nicht aus.
Okay, gut.
Und Frau, sind Sie Rentnerin?
Inzwischen bin ich Rentnerin, ja.
Mhm.
Und früher, was haben Sie gearbeitet?
Ja, also, überwiegend war ich Hausfrau, ich habe da nur mal so ein paar Gelegenheitsjobs gemacht.
Mal so eine halbe Stelle, mal jemanden betreut und mal ein bisschen im Verkauf mitgearbeitet.
Aber ich habe immer nur stundenweise gearbeitet.
Also überwiegend leben wir von der Rente meines Mannes.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon erwachsen, klar, ne?
Ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder, ja, die sind gesund, allerdings, ja.
Haben Sie auch Einzelkinder?
Bisher noch nicht.
Ja, okay, okay.
Und ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre Eltern.
Weil meine Eltern, die sind doch schon lange tot.
Okay, okay.
Aber ich würde wissen, warum oder woran sind Sie gestorben?
Ach, die sind beide alt geworden.
Aber mein Vater hatte letztendlich einen Herz infarkt.
Und meine Mutter, da wissen wir gar nicht so genau, letztendlich ist sie ein Alterschwächer gestorben.
Was da noch dahinter war, wissen wir nicht.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Kühl, ich bin mit meinem Fragen fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas zuvogeln oder haben Sie meine Fragen?
Ja, ich möchte natürlich wissen, woher das jetzt kommt und was man dagegen tun kann.
Und ja, wann ich wieder richtig essen kann und vor allem, dass die Schmerzen aufhören und diese schreckliche Übelkeit.
Ja, ja, Frau Kühl, ich kann nachvollziehen, dass Sie die Urse herbeschwerden möchten, möglichst schnell wissen möchten.
Aber zurzeit habe ich eine Verdacht auf, eine Verdacht auf, aber um eine richtige Diagnose zu schstellen, müssen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen, so wie Könther Schiedung.
Untersuchungen? Ja, was für Untersuchungen machen wir denn hier?
Ja, so erst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen durchführen und werde ihnen Blut abnehmen und richtige Parameter kontrollieren.
Dann könnte es sein, ich werde eine Ultraschall veranlasen, ab dem Bauch Ultraschall veranlasen.
Ja, dann können wir über richtige Diagnose sprechen.
Ah, ja, okay, gut.
Danke schön. Die Zeit ist schon vorbei.
Ja, halt 1 Minuten, ja, okay.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch eine Frage?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Ja?
Frau Kühl, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie einigen Tage über Bauchschmerzen haben. Könnten Sie genau sagen, seit wann haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Ach, das hat angefangen, hat das so vor 10 Tagen fast 2 Wochen, keine Ahnung. Am Anfang nimmt man das ja nicht so wahr, wenn das nur ein bisschen weh tut, dann sagt man ja, gut ist halt so.
Aber als es dann immer schlimmer geworden ist, ja, jetzt eben seit 2 Tagen, ist es richtig doll und das aber vorher ja so ungefähr 10 Tage, 10 Tage vielleicht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und nächste Frage, waren Sie deswegen schon mal beim Haushalts?
Nein, ich habe das Ding jetzt nach dem Wochenende, wurde es besonders schlimm, mein Haushalts ist im Urlaub, deswegen bin ich direkt hierhergekommen.
Okay, danke schön.
Mhm.
Okay, noch eine Frage, Kollegen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte.
Sind Sie nicht immer so dauerhaft oder gehen weg?
Ganz weg gehen tun Sie nicht, nein, Sie sind eigentlich dauerhaft, Sie sind nur schlimmer direkt nach dem Essen und als ich dann mich übergeben habe, hatte ich das Gefühl, ich fühle mich ein kleines bisschen besser, ja.
Aber ganz weg sind Sie nie.
Okay, danke schön.
Okay, haben noch andere Fragen, Kollegen?
Ich möchte einige kleine Fragen stellen.
Ach, ach, das war eine Überraschung.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Augen oder Haut in der Zeit merklich geworden oder blässig sind?
Blasser.
Blasser oder gelbisch geworden sind?
Blasser oder gelbisch, naja, also so genau habe ich nicht hingeguckt, aber eigentlich ist mir nichts besonderes aufgefallen, vielleicht sehe ich ein bisschen blasser aus als sonst, ja, könnte schon sein.
Okay.
Eine kleine Frage, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie die Köfenack 15 mg bei Bedarf eingenommen, wie viel Mal täglich?
Ja, wenn die Schmerzen ganz doll sind, nehme ich das bis zu 3 Mal, ja.
Ihre Vater, wegen Herzinfarkt gestorben ist?
Der ist auch am Herzinfarkt gestorben, ja.
Ach, der war schon alt, der war 83.
83, okay.
Meine Frage ist,
sind Sie voll geimpft gegen Corona oder Kinderkrankheiten?
Gegen Corona bin ich natürlich geimpft, ja.
Und Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, gegen Kinderkrankheiten seinerzeit auch.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was da fehlen könnte.
Und Reiser, ne?
Ja.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Ich? Nein, nein, nein, wir sind gar nicht viel viel unterwegs.
Okay, vielleicht bin Sie ich Sport?
Nein, wirklich nicht mehr.
Früher mal, wie gesagt, als junges Mädchen, da habe ich Handball gespielt und da ist das auch mit dem Knie passiert.
Und ja, dann bin ich eine Zeit noch viel Fahrrad gefahren, aber jetzt mache ich keinen Sport mehr.
Für die folgende Frage, sollen wir stellen, Frau Gerhard.
Sie haben gesagt, 3-4 Mal in der Woche abend ein Glas Wein.
Noch andere, oder wie viele Jahre?
Diese Frage ist notwendig oder?
So genau werden Sie keine Auskunft bekommen.
Ja, also ich halte diese Frage sowieso für relativ kritisch, weil sie in Deutschland wahrscheinlich von keinem ehrlich beantwortet wird.
Es sei denn, jemand ist strikter Antialkoholiker und trinkt nie irgendwas.
Ja, alle anderen würde ich mal überhaupt nügen.
Ja, ja, das wird so sein.
Ja, keiner wird Ihnen erzählen, dass er jeden Abend 4 Flaschen Bier trinkt und dann sein muss noch 2 Schnäppchen.
Das binden die Ihnen nicht auch die Namen, das erzählen die Leute Ihnen nicht.
Sondern die werden das immer schön nach unten korrigieren.
Und wenn die jetzt sagt, sie trinkt 3-4 Mal in der Woche, trinkt sie abends ein Glas Wein, dann macht sie das wahrscheinlich schon seit mehreren Jahren.
Aber die wird nicht sagen, wahrscheinlich hat sie früher mal deutlich mehr getrunken.
Als sie jung war, hat sie vielleicht Schnaps und Bier getrunken in der Kneipe.
Und jetzt ist sie halt ein bisschen solider und kann sich Wein leisten.
Jetzt trinkt sie abends halt mein Glas Wein.
Können wir sagen, Alkohol ab Usus, diese Patiente?
Nein, nein.
Sie würde sich strikt dagegen wehren, wenn sie ihr ein Alkohol ab Usus unterstellen.
Okay, danke.
Also, ja, also da darf es, also bei Nikotin ab Usus würde ich Ihnen recht geben.
Ja, wenn jemand seit 20 Jahren 20 Zigaretten am Tag rauf, würde ich sagen, ja, Nikotin ab Usus schon, ja.
Aber für hiesige Verhältnisse ist es ein moderater Alkoholkonsum.
Ja, moderater.
Okay.
Können wir erst das Geschenk beantragen?
Können wir auch immer.
Einmal Stimme ölen.
Schönen guten Tag, sehr verehrte Frau Oberarson.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen besprechen.
Darf ich so erst die Patienten vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich, gerne.
Okay, die Patientin heißt Anna Kiel.
Sie ist 87 Jahre alt.
Was?
67.
67 Jahre alt.
Entschuldigung.
Und er ist 79 Kilogramm schwer und 1,68 Meter groß.
Frau Kiel stellte sich bei uns wegen seit 2 Tagen bestehender, dumfer, durkender Schmerzen im Abdomen oder im Epigastrische.
Epigastrische, von der Frau.
Frau.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt 7 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
7 von 10.
Und die Patienten sind sofort die Schmerzen nach dem Essen schlimm geworden.
Aus der Berichtete, dass sie diese Schmerzen seit 7 Tagen haben, aber im Laufe der Zeit schlimme geworden seien.
Aber im Laufe der Zeit seien die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden.
Okay.
2 Mal.
Und so.
Ja, auch Reistusten.
Und vegetative Anamnese, seit einige Auffälligkeiten, insbesondere Hyperhidros in Appetence, und Gewicht zu nehmen.
Zunahme?
Zunahme, ja, da die Patienten habe regelmäßig Prednisolone eingenommen wegen Romatoid Atritis.
Und ja, auch Schmerzbedickte Insomni.
Ja, du hast schlafen.
Jetzt die letzten Tage hat sie nicht geschlafen.
Ja.
Und vor Erkorkung, sie leide an Romatoid Atritis arterielle Hypertonie seit 7 Jahren.
Sie wurde Prednisolone 5 mg morgens und Kapterbrill 25 mg morgens abends und die Klophaniac 50 mg bei Bedarf eingenommen.
Sie sahen, dass die Kreuzband-Rissen in Jugendjahren operiert wurden.
Sie hatte einen Sportunfall gehabt.
Ah ja.
Sie war 20 Jahre alt und hat 3-4 Mal Glas Wein pro Woche.
Sie hat einen Nippotingkonsum.
Sie hat einen Rogunkonsum.
Sie hat keine Allergie.
Sie hat keine Allergie?
Ja, und sie sei Rentnerin, früher als Hausfrau Verkauferin, verheiratet.
Sie war Hausfrau und hat stundenweise als Verkäuferin gearbeitet.
Sie haben Kinder und sind gesund.
Sie haben ihre Kinder und Kinder in der Familie gestorben.
Sie haben mit 3 Jahren gestorben.
Sie haben eine Altherbedingste-Krankheit gestorben.
Sie haben eine Art Erkrankung.
Ich warte Anime.
Bei der kleine Blutbild erwarte ich Anime.
Ich würde Lipase, Amylase, CRP und Leberwerte.
Eine Sache ist noch wichtig.
Wir müssen vielleicht operieren.
Wir müssen alles substituieren.
Wenn sie eine Konserve braucht, müssen sie wissen.
Die Blutgruppe wäre nicht schlecht.
Ich werde auch Finger- oder Rektaluntersuchung.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, dass es eine schwere Stuhlgang gibt.
Was würden Sie mit der digitalen Rektalen untersuchen?
Ich werde auch Iphob testen.
Aber die Frage ist anders.
Sie können feststellen, dass die Frau Hemorrhiden hat.
Aber die Hemorrhiden machen keine Melena.
Sie können feststellen, ob sie Melena hat.
Welches Bildgebende verfahren kommt zum Einsatz?
Ich kann Röntgenabdomen veranlassen.
Was machen Sie vorher?
Was machen Sie erst?
Ich würde erst Abdomen-Sonographie.
Was machen Sie jetzt mit der Inversiver-Untersuchung?
Das ist das Thema.
Wie sieht es aus in den Magen?
Wenn Blutung oder Geschwör in der Magen befunden wird,
würde ich gerne Flüssigkeit zuvor und Oraleinnahme stoppen.
Legen Sie als erstes einen guten Zugang.
Wenn es eine Blutung ist, muss man schauen, wie man die Blutung stoppen.
Wenn man feststellt, dass es ein Ulkos ist,
dann kommen wir zur Ulkostiagnostik und Ulkosterapie.
Ich bin gespannt, was der Frau Kehl fehlt.
Wir haben noch ein paar sprachliche Probleme.
Ich bin jemand, der weiß, wovon sie reden und worum es geht.
Wer das Thema nicht kennt, wird ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten haben, sie gut zu verstehen.
Am Anfang haben Sie die berühmte Verdrehung gemacht.
Ich habe nach meiner Facharztprüfung Studiert.
Ich habe inzwischen hin und wieder mal ein bisschen reklamiert.
Sie leidet seit 10 Jahren an Artegalahypothonie und Rollmatoida Arthritis.
Ich habe das so verstanden, sie wurde Kaptochialpretnisolone.
Sie haben sich auch bei den Familien an einem Nese ergab.
Der Vater ist im hohen Alter an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Sie schreiben nicht, sie sprechen.
Sie haben zwei Malige MSS, dabei ist ihr aufgefallen, dass neben Schweizeresten auch Blutspuren im Erbrochenen waren.
Sie beschreibt Terstühle bzw. Melena seit zwei Tagen.
Das kann man alles in vernünftigen Sätzen sagen.
Hier ist es als Diagnose aufgeführt, obere gastrointestinale Blutung.
Das ist natürlich ein Oberbegriff, das kann viele Gründe haben.
Aber klar ist das erst mal das, was wir vermuten müssen, dass sie eine Blutung hat.
Das haben sie auch gesagt, das erwarten sie in der Augendiagnostik, also in dem, was sie sehen mit ihren Augen.
Das erwarten sie im Blutbild.
Und letztendlich die Untersuchung, das haben sie ja alles komplett beschrieben.
Wie gesagt, Sprali ist es ein bisschen schwierig.
Es ist einfach ein breiter Akzent, da man dort nicht raus hört.
Den kann man nicht immer gut verstehen.
Also versuchen sie das noch ein bisschen zu korrigieren, zu üben.
Dann müssen wir gucken.
Donnerstag gibt es ein Münchner Fall.
Extra für Sie, vielleicht haben wir Glück und es ist der Richtige.
Dr. Gündest?
Vielen Dank. Donnerstag um 20 Uhr.
Ich denke, dass wir eine sehr wertvolle Information haben,
für nicht nur Kollegen, sondern auch alles.
Für alle.
Sehr gute Informationen. Vielen Dank.
Schönen Abend für Sie alle. Erholen Sie sich gut.
Tschüss und bis übermorgen.
Danke schön.